de Flickr. Allez à droite,
choisissez Flickr de la liste d'options,
glissez-le dans la timeline,
mettez-le où vous le souhaitez,
et il va immédiatement sur Flickr et commence à importer
les images basées sur les tags. Mes développeurs
aiment beaucoup les poneys, et donc ils ont mis cela comme tag par défaut.
Essayons autre chose,
peut-être quelque chose en rapport à aujourd'hui.
Voici les images importées en direct du flux.
Si vous revenez voir ceci dans une semaine,
ça sera complètement différent,
dynamique, tout comme le web, et tout comme le web,
tout a une source, donc cliquez sur le lien,
et vous allez directement sur Flickr voir l'image d'origine.
Tout ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui est fait avec
les bases de construction du web : du HTML, CSS et JavaScript.
Ce qui veut dire que c'est complètement remixable.
Et qu'il n'y a pas de logiciel propriétaire. Vous n'avez besoin
que d'un navigateur web.
Imaginez si toutes les vidéos que nous regardions sur le web
marchaient comme le web, seraient complètement remixables,
liées au contenu d'origine, et interactives
pour toute personne qui les regarderait.
Je pense que Popcorn pourrait changer la façon dont nous racontons les histoires
sur le web, et la façon dont nous comprenons le monde dans lequel nous vivons.
Merci. (Applaudissements)